everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be going
over Game five of the 2014 World Chess
Championship between Vichy and on and
magnus carlsen the reigning champion
just to give you a quick recap Game one
we had a draw game to Magnus Carlsen
took the lead playing the white pieces
fishing on came back playing the white
pieces and Game three to even things up
and in Game four Magnus Carlsen drew
with the white pieces we're in Game five
Vichy and on is going to be playing the
white pieces Magnus Carlsen is gonna be
playing the black pieces as fishing on
usually does he starts out with pawn to
d4 pretty interesting to see how -
Carlson's going to respond so far he
hasn't played very well when he's
playing black against the pawn to d4 so
he starts out with Knight to f6 pawn
here to c4 and then pawn here to e6 kind
of waiting to see where his opponent's
going to go Knight to c3 typically goes
into the nimzo-indian offense with
bishop here to be for a lot of players
when they start with pawn to d4 pawn to
c4 when their opponents play this Knight
to f6 pawn to e6 opening up the door for
the dice for Bishop they will first play
Knight to f3 and that's what Vichy and
on does but this usually goes to a
Queen's Indian defense and so that's
what Magnus Carlsen employs and he plays
pawn here to b6 now in the Queen's
Indian defense again it's kind of hyper
modern defense where you're trying to
control the center of the board with
your minor pieces and then later you
start to push forward and counter-attack
with your pawns white usually responds
as vision on does by playing pawn here
to g3 getting ready to feed kin to his
bishop here on g2 and then for a lot of
the game there's gonna be kind of this
power struggle on the light squares both
of these bishops are feeding keto on
opposite sides so they're both trying to
control this area of the board which is
a very uncommon practice on you know on
the chess board you don't see very often
so definitely pretty exciting one of the
more aggressive defenses the black and
half so really interested to see how
mine is crossing comes out of the
Queen's in the end offense and how
vision on attacks it Magnus responds
with Bishop here to b4 first and then we
see bishop here to addy - a little bit
different again
and the night being here on c3 and then
there could be an exchange double pawns
here on the C file machine on doesn't
have to deal with that so Bishop here to
e7 then we see the Knights of c3 so
things are okay now Bishop here to b7
trying to control this long diagonal
right here we see Bishop here to g2 now
Magnus Carlsen has a few options what
he's kind of learned in the past is
fishing on is very prepared for the
World Championships that may seem kind
of an obvious magnus carlsen even
mentioned in the press conference
because they speak to these players
after every match that he was surprised
by how prepared vichy anon was in this
tournament so far as far as theoretical
chess going over kind of all the main
lines and all the the theories that are
to go into all these deep openings and
all the variations machine on seemed to
have studied more than he did the last
time so magnus carlsen kind of mentioned
that he wanted to stay away from
theoretical lines as much as possible
because fishing on may be more prepared
than him and he didn't want to give any
advantage to his opponent so with that
said he wanted to stay away from the
more theoretical lines the more common
lines that Vichy and on may have
prepared for those lines being castling
on the Kings side
Knight to c6 these are the more common
line so Magnus Carlsen decided to try a
little bit different variation you
played pawn here to c6 which allows him
to kind of push forward with pawn here
to d5 in the center trying to control
the these light squares and bishan on
took a little while to respond to this
he it almost seemed like he was confused
by Magnus Carlsen display he didn't want
to fall for any traps that Magnus
Carlsen will may have employed on him he
ended up with going with pawn to e4
which i think is the correct way to
attack this and again is putting all of
his mines towards this light square he
also has his minor pieces on that as
well Magnus Carlsen pushes forward with
pawn to d5 and then vision on just
immediately plays pawn takes here on d5
so
look like for just a split second he
wanted to just make sure his mind was
not playing tricks on him that this was
one of the lines that he had prepared
for and then when magnus carlsen did
play that d5 he Amelie played this so it
was kind of making sure that magnus
carlsen knew that even this crazy line
that you don't see very often there
hasn't been too much theory behind it
Vichy nom was still ready so magnus
carlsen was gonna have to try something
else or else Vietnam was gonna be
probably the more prepared person we now
see magnus carlsen take with his pawn
any time you're thinking about how the
capture you typically want to capture
towards the center of the board so if
you kind of look at this the pawn taking
here on on d5 from the e post magnus
carlsen now only has one central spawn
and it's gonna be a little easy easier
for vision on to attack this efile
compare that to - Carlsen taking right
here he has two central pawns he's a
very nice pawn chain right here and it
also opens up the door for his knight to
come here to c6 so all in all it's not
always the case but generally you want
to be capturing towards the stare of the
board giving yourself more central pawns
is always going to be better so Magnus
Carlsen takes with his C pawn and then
we see Knight here to e5 we see castle
and then we see castle we now see Knight
to c6 magnus carlsen continuing his
development here machine on taking on d5
adding more pressure on magnus carlsen
there's a few different ways that magnus
carlsen can defend he could take here on
e5 if he wants to he could take with
this night here on d5 he could recapture
with his pawn here on d5 he decides to
go and play Knight taking here on e5
fishing on has two main options his
first option which he didn't choose is
the pawn taking here on e5 now kind of
forcing the knight to recapture here on
d5 and then the rooks coming over here
to see one controlling this long file
that's one option he chose a different
route which i think is a pretty good
move is chignon plays pawn here to d6
with a discovered attack with this
bishop on the square here on b7
it's attacking that only this
LightSquared bishop the dark square
bishop and the night here on e5 so
putting a lot of pressure
on his opponent magnus carlsen
recognizing that one of those pieces is
going to fall decides he wants to hold
on to his knight so he plays Knight to
c6 and then machine on takes and then
the Queen recaptures and then the Queen
this Bishop comes up here to g5 allowing
for the Queen here on d1 to defend the
square here on d4 and also attacking
this Knight and putting it down to the
queen pawn here to h6 forcing this
bishop to move but visi and on has other
plans instead of moving this bishop
first he decides to go and play pawn
here to d5 again putting his opponent to
the test which is kind of what we've
seen from the last game the vision on
one with the white pieces he was really
the aggressor and so that's kind of what
he's doing right now
a pawn here to d5 Magnus Carlsen doesn't
want to just take you know pawn taking
here on d5 because the Knight to d5 all
of a sudden this is a problem the knight
can't capture because it's again it's
being pinned down right here all of a
sudden the Queen is kind of forced to
move the Queen may come here to e6 wants
to make sure it's still holding on to
this material right here or else white
would just be up in material but now we
just see the bishop take the Queen can't
take again because it's being attacked
by the knight but if the pawn takes then
all of a sudden Knight to c7 forking
both the rook and the Queen so that's
gonna be bad he doesn't like that option
so instead he decides to go ahead and
play Knight to a5 now this he needs to
be very careful Magnus Carlsen he can't
bring his Knights back here to b7
he can't bring it to c6 he can't bring
it here to b3 his only square is c4 so
fishing on can find a way to attack the
square here on c4 and then play you know
pawn here to be for all of a sudden
Magnus Carlsen is going to be in a lot
of trouble so definitely Magnus Carlsen
needs to make sure that later on he gets
this knight involved into the game
fishing on takes here on f6 then we see
the queen recapture doesn't want to take
with his pawn it just kind of opens up
the door for his King to be attacked
Queen here to g4 threatening after the
King moves he could continue with his
attack you know Queen to h4 forcing the
King to come up here to h7 he could at
any time just
a pawn here to b4 now that the Queen
Vichy and on is attacking the square
here on c4 this night all of a sudden
can't really go anywhere and so this is
definitely going to be not very good for
Magnus Carlsen and so he decides to go
ahead and take with his queen on board
so now we see the pawn take here on e6
machine on just decided that he didn't
want to have to deal with all of his
pieces tied up trying to defend his
isolated pawn here on the D file so just
gave it up it would have been nice if he
tried to push for maybe a promotion
maybe put more pressure on his opponent
if he got his pawn up here to d7 but
just didn't want to in the particular
game we now see the Queen's take here on
e6 rook to e1 centralising attacking
this Queen Queen back here to f6 Knight
to d5 pretty interesting move on board
and this kind of made Magnus Carlsen
think for a while this was a critical
move in the game a lot of grandmaster
said this was a pretty nice initiative
of vichy and on to try to play out for
the win
so centralizing Magnus Carlsen
eventually decided to take with his
bishop he just wanted to give as much
material off the board as possible so
this bishops going to come up here and
the Magnus Carlsen plays rook to d8 then
we see the Queen coming here to f3
defending this and attacking this Queen
we see the Queen come down here
capturing material on b2 then this works
gonna centralize machine on just trying
to control this here the board he can
get the material back if he needs to
Magnus Carlsen really just wants to
trade he kind of forces with this move
back here for Vichy and on to trade so
we do see an exchange on the board and
from here all sides kind of said that
it's gonna be very tough a forward
vision on to play for point without his
queen now if he could potentially get a
passed pawn maybe put a lot of pressure
on his opponent because he does have a
bishop a bishop if there's to pawn
chains on either side of the board
definitely has a lot more mobility than
the night a knight usually does a lot
better if there's just one pawn chain so
if all if all these pawns over here on
the Queen side were off and the night
was over here it would be better than
the bishop
but they said okay this bishop here on
d5 it can swing all over the board so
maybe a slight advantage but definitely
after the Queen comes off it's
definitely going to be very difficult
for non so looking for manage Carlsen to
maybe make a mistake or try to find a
passed pawn that he can maybe add more
pressure to magnus carlsen the rook up
here to e7 always want to control the
seventh rank of your opponent King to g7
again both the rook and the bishop here
attacking this square right here but
right now Magnus Carlsen has both his
rook and his kingdom finding it but also
wants to make sure that he is defending
the other pawns right here since he has
doubled pawns on the F file we now see
the RIC swing over here to a7 gobble up
this material so fishing on Z equalized
in material you can start to add more
pressure to his opponent we now see
Knight to c6 and this I thought was
another very interesting move in the
game right now
fishing on can definitely play for a
point it'd be a difficult point but he
has his pawn over here on a 2 he can
really try to hold on to this material
play rook to a4 this could definitely
hold on to it but in the game fishing on
played rook here to b7 and this really
is just kind of saying let's just move
on to the next game let's just exchange
off all material play for a draw
Magnus Carlsen plays Knights of b4 and
we see some exchanging off the board and
then the knight taking here on a2 and
all of a sudden machine on doesn't have
the pawn over here on the a file
all of a sudden magnus carlsen now has
the better minor piece since there's one
set of pawn chains over here on the
Kings side and so it's gonna be very
difficult for her either player to find
an in game where they can get a full
point so the Knights gonna start
swinging over here to the King side both
sides at this point they were almost
playing blitz chess that you know this
is all in game theory that both sides
have kind of mastered right here we do
see an exchange off the board and right
now
very very draw in game there's no way
for either side to have a real advantage
so they just kind of went through a few
moves just to see if anyone was going to
make a mistake and then all of a sudden
we see after the thirty-ninth move it
only took two and a half hours so
definitely a short game we never hit
time control for either players so they
were kind of going through this pretty
fast but this situation that decided to
draw so I was a little disappointed you
know fishing on came out the gates
played extremely well Magnus Carlsen a
few times kind of put fishing on to the
test he tried to be pretty aggressive
but then in the end it almost seemed
like he lost steam maybe not sure if he
was prepared for some of the variations
Magnus Carlsen put him into but
definitely at the end didn't go with
some of the more aggressive lines that
he could have maybe he just thought
Magnus Carlson's in game was was better
so decides to just go ahead and accept
the draw and move on so tomorrow Magnus
Carlsen will come back for Game six with
the white pieces and try to for the
first half again there's 12 games so try
to come out of the first half with a win
but so far pretty exciting stuff from
the the chest World Championship
hopefully you guys are enjoying the
commentary you're learning stuff and
watching these two great players play so
I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching